Let's talk real quick about the
temporal dead zone. This is a
bit of a boring topic, so I'm
going to try and make it really
fun for you. This is something
that you probably won't come
across too often, but it's
helpful to know in case someone
ever slings it out in an
interview. You'd be able to talk
them about it. First of all, I
call it the temporal dad zone,
which is kind of fun. Let's
make a var variable called pizza
and set it to deep dish, and
we'll put a pizza emoji in there.
What happens when you try and
console log pizza after it's
been created. You'll see that we
actually get to see deep dish,
right? No big issue there. What
if I try to console log it
before? Are we going to get a)
Undefined, b) Pizza is not yet
defined error, or c) Are we
actually going to see the word
deep dish with the pizza emoji?
We get a) Undefined. Undefined,
why? Because with var variables,
you can actually access them as
they are defined. Before they
are defined, you cannot access
the actual value of them, but
you can access the fact that the
variable has been created before.
If I change that to const or let,
you'll now see that pizza is not
defined at all. That's an actual
error, and that will break your
code. That is called the
temporal dead zone, where you
cannot access a variable before
it is defined. They mean that
this is the temporal dead zone
right here, because you cannot
access it before it has been
created. That's pretty much it.
That's all you need to know. Put
that in your back pocket,
because you'll need it someday.